here I love this guy it's just like that
you're gonna squeeze the top button to
SL and then as you're moving as you're
squeezing the milk downwards the more
vibrates the reward squirts
okay so you're gonna feel HD in the joy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh sure we can contest is one player oh
you guys are gonna compete in contests
so so you'll notice he's got the right
joy Khan which has the iron motion
camera inches away from your mouth so
you want to hold it two inches away from
your mouth the key don't put it in your
mouth break your teeth don't and then
you want to hold the joist on the key is
holding the joy Khan steady as you chop
these sandwiches every time I've seen
this the eyes naturally squint ah that's
great nice alright alright so I will
give you the joy Khan robbed tasty and
we're gonna just say yeah I recommend ya
hold it kind of like if you just hold it
kind of your palm like this it should be
yeah
just the key is it's gonna be steady
yeah oh and then up to your mouth and
then open your mouth and hold your mouth
open and keep it open okay this is the
longest I've seen someone get it up
there hoping around I think I don't know
if your mouth was open yeah I was
confused yeah I've never I've never
eaten like this
like this and then like you hold your
mouth okay like a giant okay hold it
hold it hold it keep your hand steady in
your mouth open
Hey
eight nine is what we're trying to be
[Applause]
Daniel yeah he plays before
no yes
what I like it